buenas tardes
en todos hemos escuchado historias que
nos hablan de la naturaleza en las
culturas indígenas y en la mapuche en
particular hay muchas
y en esas historias nos cuentan de la
creación del mundo de los roles de las
personas
y en la cultura mapuche se dice que el
ser humano debe estar en equilibrio con
la naturaleza que el desarrollo humano
no puede sobrepasar a la naturaleza
y estas historias se transmiten a través
de la palabra
en la cultura originaria en general la
palabra es el dispositivo que permite
crear el mundo crear la realidad con la
palabra se puede construir la historia
con la palabra también se puede hacer la
paz y con las palabras también se puede
usarla se puede crear la guerra por lo
tanto la palabra es muy importante el
respeto que se le debe tener y en este
contexto
en hombres y mujeres tienen la misión de
cuidar tanto la palabra como cuidar la
naturaleza y cuidarse entre ellos yo les
voy a hablar de la mujer mapuche que
tiene también la conexión con el mundo
con la naturaleza y su misión con la
palabra
como ustedes saben cuando llegaron los
españoles se creó un mito duro frente a
los pueblos originarios y dentro de esto
alonso de ercilla y zúñiga que llegó a
chile en 1557 y que escribió el poema
épico la araucana retrata a la mujer
indígena en un pasaje donde habla de
precio caupolicán y muestra aprecia y
dice fresia cuando toman preso a su
marido le dice que ella no quiere tener
títulos de madre de un niño infame hijo
de padre infame y le lanza el hijo por
los pies
la metáfora hizo muy mal a la visión que
se tiene de la mujer indígena porque se
muestra como una mujer primitiva que no
tiene sentido del amor y de el cuidado y
la protección de los niños
y esta visión también uno la puede
arrastrar por de diferentes posturas
porque las visiones que se tienen
depende del objetivo con las cuales se
transmiten se dice por ejemplo hay
visiones que son de tipo folclóricas y
en éstas se dice que la machi que toda
mujer que usa un traje tradicional se le
ve como machi no obstante la mancha es
una persona que tiene un poder
espiritual y un conocimiento particular
con el cual puede sanar a la humanidad y
en eso no todas las mujeres pueden ser
macho desde el punto de vista también se
puede ver desde otra mirada y se dice
que la que este personaje más chic es
chamán
se dedica a la ciencia oculta que no son
la ciencia particularmente las que
nosotros solamente conocemos no obstante
en la cultura mapuche la ciencia que
conocemos también está presente y en
este contexto yo les tengo que para
comprender esta historia es importante
conocer cómo se genera el pensamiento en
la cultura mapuche y cómo se organiza el
conocimiento para eso voy a mostrar este
esquema que ustedes ven ahí y donde
aparece el lof es el espacio donde nace
la comunidad y dónde viven las personas
las mujeres y los hombres y aparece en
otro color la palabra hecho film o bien
que es la biodiversidad el mundo en su
totalidad los seres humanos tienen que
sentir el mundo en su totalidad y en su
plenitud se marca en azul la parte que
más relacionado a la observación al
conocimiento que nace de la observación
y posteriormente aparece la palabra la
palabra como un código de ética
transmisión de la verdad y cuando uno
transmite la palabra cuando uno da
vuelta a cada uno de los pétalos recién
uno puede hablar de que se tiene al
sabio oa la savia pues entonces de la
historia donde yo les hablo pertenecen a
este paradigma de de conocimiento en
este contexto
la la oralidad es el instrumento que nos
permite llegar a los saberes yo también
estoy de acuerdo con la que la que la
escritura de la lengua que es una vía
también para mantener la cultura no
obstante en este contexto de oralidad ya
le señalaba la importancia que tiene la
palabra
hay una investigadora que es clarita
5 la que ella es una mujer
[Música]
es una mujer es una psicóloga que se
dedicó a estudiar los relatos
tradicionales sobre mujeres y ella
plantea en su libro mujeres que corren
con los de 2001 ella dice que llama a
las mujeres a volver a reencontrarse con
sus raíces a reencontrarse con la
creatividad y con la intuición y dice
que la mujer moderna está sobrepasada
por la modernidad y la verdad que ha
perdido se ha distanciado mucho de su
origen y ha perdido mucho tiempo en está
en competir con el hombre y en competir
con otras mujeres dejando de lado este
rol ancestral yo les voy a hablar de la
mujer indígena actual de este mundo y
que ella está presente y puede estar en
cualquier espacio y que tiene una misión
con la palabra y con el conocimiento en
este paradigma donde yo les acaba de
presentar en este contexto nosotros
hemos aprendido de qué
uno no pasa por la tierra por pasar si
uno está herido el don de la palabra uno
se puede morir iba a desaparecer tu
cuerpo físico pero va a quedar tu
palabra va a quedar tu historia va a
quedar y si tú las órdenas también y si
tú te dedicaste a construir esa palabra
va a quedar para que otros siga
construyendo la historia
en la cultura mapuche entonces en los
relatos orales nos pueden dar esta
versión completa ahí aparece el el mundo
y en la historia se dice que la mujer
fue la que creó el mundo
la madre primigenia que estaba en el
bueno map o en el cielo ella y no había
gente hagan esta tierra que hoy día
pisamos ya decide crear la vida acá y en
ese entonces las fuerzas en el cielo
también es fuerza positiva y negativa y
ellas se pelearon con tanta fuerza que
al pelear acá cayeron y traspasaron este
espacio de la tierra el magma
que le llamamos y entraron al [ __ ]
mapa que es la tierra subterránea y en
la tierra subterránea quedaron atrapadas
con su fuerza pudieron salir una de
ellas salieron y formaron las montañas y
la otra también salieron y querían
volver al cielo pero no pudieron y
quedaron en suspenso colgado en este
espacio y formaron la lluvia a partir de
la lluvia se formó el río se formó el
mar y la tierra quedó con montaña con
agua sin embargo todavía no tenía vida
humana entonces la madre primigenia a la
abuela mandó a su hija a la tierra y la
mujer niña joven caminó sobre la tierra
y al caminar sus pies sangraron y de ese
sangrado brotó el pasto brotaron las
mariposas las flores entonces la tierra
se llenó de colores y se llenó de ruido
y de sonidos
estando eso construido la madre
primigenia decidió mandar al hombre y
cuando bueno llega al hombre acá le dan
una misión a la pareja a primigenia
también de la tierra nuestro antepasado
y le dicen ustedes tienen que cuidar su
comunidad cuidarse entre ustedes hacer
ceremonia hablar su idioma cuidar la
naturaleza así fue la misión después de
eso y ya en los tiempos modernos y si
uno va para el sector de licán ray
coñaripe uno puede encontrar la historia
de la época que poca es la mujer de la
montaña ella vive en la montaña y tiene
una casa enorme que tiene muchos víveres
el grano papá y en la noche ya está en
su casa con un fogón y cuando pasa a la
gente cuando pasan los hombres pasan a
su casa y oye le sirve mate le sirve de
comida pero ella tiene una parte que en
realidad no quiere que nadie se la vea y
que son justamente sus pies y no quieren
que se las vea porque sus pies tienen
forma de vudú entonces si el hombre con
ser
la atención en sus pies ella se enoja e
inmediatamente todo desaparece
desaparece la casa desaparece la comida
al fogón y ella se mete se pierde entre
los bosques como una común pudo entonces
qué poca vive en la montaña y cuando
quiere anunciar la lluvia ella canta y
cuando las mujeres quieren tienen mucho
trabajo para atender a la ceremonia ella
baja de los cerros en la noche y ayuda y
termina los trabajos al otro día las
mujeres se levantan y ya está todo listo
esa es la historia de qué poca la
historia de otra mujer que la mujer del
arco iris la mujer del arco iris una
niña que en la pradera juega pequeña
juega con arco iris pequeño juega con
arco iris pequeño y luego sus brazos se
transforman como si fueran en arco iris
y tiene a los colores de el morado el
amarillo al verde y luego ella en su
sueño también tiene metamorfosis y se
transforma y desde su cuerpo le nace en
hoja le nacen flores entonces se vuelve
una mujer como árbol
y esa es una mujer que tiene el poder
del arco iris y con esa misión con ese
poder
ella también actúa para sanar a la
comunidad sanar a los enfermos la última
mujer de la cual le voy a abrir a hablar
es sobre la mujer del trueno la mujer
del trueno también es una niña que su
padre cuando ella era pequeña se sueña
de que la niña estaba sentado a la urna
no roca y viene un gran estruendo y
luego cae un rayo y cerca de ella el
hombre tuve sueño y fue a ver a la niña
y cuando va a ver a la niña la nieve
lloraba con el tiempo la niña se le
revela el poder de machín del chamán de
la mujer curandera entonces ella se
transforma en curandera con el poder del
trueno es siendo machi en su comunidad
en su casa en su recinto tenía una
arboleda grande de frutas y dentro de al
medio de eso también había un árbol
nativo que es el árbol nativo del boldo
yo creo que ustedes lo conocen ese árbol
nativo estaba conectado al poder del
trueno
no estaba conectado con ella estaba
conectada con otras más antiguas del
pasado que tenían el poder del trueno
era en la época 2010 cuando empezaron a
la política del estado empezó a
financiar proyectos para plantar los
pinos y lo hace eucalipto todo lo que
era la plata la plantación exótica
entonces los hermanos de ésta machi
optaron por recibir el ofrecimiento del
gobierno y no encontraron nada mejor que
cortar los árboles y cortar el boldo
obviamente la magia al ver eso y era su
conexión de vida espiritual ella se
enferma y casi moribunda ella dice bueno
porque lo hicieron porque con esto están
destruyendo mi vida y la de los
antepasados y de las otras mujeres que
van a que tendrían que recibir esta
energía para sanar
y hace la ceremonia como pudo y en la
ceremonia ya supo y le advirtió a sus
hermanos que tuvieran cuidado porque
ellos iban a tener algún problema por lo
que habían hecho a la semana a los
jóvenes mueren y ella logra que el árbol
nuevamente de su retoño de nuevamente
crezca nuevamente pueda dar su su vida
entonces con esta historia que yo les
cuento son de mujeres que tienen su
mente conectada con la naturaleza pero
la naturaleza no solamente como un ente
es romántico sino una naturaleza que
también le enseña una naturaleza que
también entrega fuerza 2 y yo me
pregunto muchas veces como investigadora
qué hace que una mujer mapuche o una
mujer indígena que ha vivido la
discriminación racial posee por ser
mujer o que ha vivido el machismo que
hace que ella continúa enseñando lengua
enseñando sobre su cultura llevando su
traje a todas partes que que les lleva a
que le moviliza la respuesta que
encuentro es a través de esta de estas
oralidad es donde uno puede ver que si
ahí tiene sentido todo lo que hace
porque es simplemente es cumplir con el
mandato que tiene en esta en esta vida
entonces
es bien importante que en la situación
en que nos encontramos
con el calentamiento global estas
historias no solamente tienen que
saberlo los indígenas los mapuches sino
que toda la civilización toda la
sociedad tendría que conocerla por eso
yo les invito a ustedes a conocer las
historias originarias a querer las a
valorar las porque solamente queriendo
amando eso ustedes van a poder valorar y
ustedes van a poder conocerlas porque
ahora la tierra no solo necesita a los
mapuches que defiendan su vida sino que
también necesita de todas las nuevas
generaciones para que vuelvan a cuidar
el río a cuidar las aguas a defender los
árboles a repoblar con el árbol nativo
porque eso es lo que aquí le da la vida
le da vida a este territorio entonces en
ese contexto
también es importante que asumamos la
palabra como el contenido que traslada
estos saberes como este dispositivo y no
usar la palabra en vano sino usarla para
llevar el conocimiento para amar y no
para crear los conflictos y continuar
con los problemas de la guerra que
también nos afectan y que estamos viendo
a diario desde la televisión en esta
desde esta misma mirada en el tema y el
trabajo que hace la mujer el mapuche es
también otro conocimiento que no nos
puede ayudar a continuar una vida mucho
más equilibrada entre el ser humano con
la naturaleza porque nosotros los seres
humanos no somos más que la fuerza de la
naturaleza si el río se seca si la
montaña se destruye nosotros también nos
destruimos y también avanzamos hacia el
paso del silencio a un mundo callado sin
ruidos sin pájaros
sin colores por el contrario si nosotros
volvemos a repoblar nuestro territorio
con las plantas originarias de acá si
nosotros cuidamos el agua si nosotros
vemos en la piedra también la ternura de
la naturaleza nosotros tendremos también
una naturaleza más vigorizada una
sociedad con mayor comprensión porque
esta comprensión que se promueve a
través de estos relatos es a través de
la palabra a través del diálogo y yo
creo que en eso todos podemos contribuir
y eso es lo que yo quería compartir en
esta oportunidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]